meu nome é flávia nelson psicóloga e
professora e pesquisadora
mas hoje eu não vou falar aqui sobre a
minha história eu vou contar sobre a
história de uma menina de 14 anos que
mudou minha vida
essa menina de nome de maria em uma
certa noite de novembro de 2007
estávamos eu maria e enfermeira kelle na
ambulância a caminho da internação
psiquiátrica da maria maria é como
estava muito de desenhar
gostava de brincar de boneca gostava de
fazer as unhas
mas o que ela mais gostava mesmo era de
brincar com água ela fazia assim uma
conchinha com a mão jogava no pé
jogava nas pernas jogava na cabeça podia
ficar horas e horas no banheiro fazendo
isso era difícil tirar ela de lá ficava
tanto tempo que é assim aqui o gordinho
do dedo ficava todo enrugado a maioria
vinha de uma família pobre morava com a
mãe dela e com a avó e com os outros
quatro irmãos
ela tinha sido excluída da escola e
incluído em lugar nenhum
portanto os cuidados da maria ficavam
todos a cargo da rebeca
a mãe dela acontece que maria também
tinha um outro comportamento ela tinha
rompantes de agressividade momento que
ela levantava e podia mesmo empurra ou
dá um tapa em qualquer um que estivesse
do lado
uma certa noite
maria teve essa crise de agressividade
muito forte chegou a machucar seus
irmãos é a rebeca não sabia como lidar
com isso e como rebecca estava ali
sozinha no cuidado o que ela pode fazer
foi num pronto socorro que encaminhou a
maria para a sua internação psiquiátrica
na ambulância a sensação que me lembro
de ser uma noite úmida
a chuva lá fora as bolsas na marginal os
dedos unidos da maria
o vidro embaçado na verdade as minhas
ideias
embaçados é muito estranho acompanhar
uma criança por uma internação
psiquiátrica
quando a gente chegou lá maria me fez
duas perguntas que não saíram mas a
minha cabeça ela perguntou por que eu
vou ficar aqui não tinha resposta ea
outra pergunta era quem vai sair comigo
eu também não tinha a menor idéia
não sabia dizer quem são as crianças e
adolescentes que são encaminhadas para
internação e daí começou uma pesquisa de
mestrado foi estudar
fui tentar descobrir quem era essa
população quem são as crianças e
adolescentes que são encaminhadas para a
institucionalização
eu fiz uma pesquisa no hospital caism
felipe pinel na parte da infância
adolescência e pesquisei todas as
internações que aconteceu entre 2005 e
eu estudei 601 internações para tentar
descobrir quem são essas pessoas
quem são essas crianças a internação
essa questão de porque as crianças são
internadas pra mim é uma questão muito
séria porque não pensar pensando no
tratamento em saúde mental a gente viveu
aqui no brasil anos de uma história de
asilamento durante anos da nossa
história o tratamento de saúde mental se
tratava de assimilar as pessoas de
institucionalizar né e o que isso gerou
na verdade a gente sabe que a
institucionalização no causo melhor nos
sintomas muito menos melhora na
qualidade de vida
esses anos de institucionalização
geraram um contingente enorme de pessoas
que aos poucos se tornaram moradores de
instituições teve um censo em 2009 do
estado de são paulo que apontou para a
existência de mais de 6 mil pessoas
moradoras do hospital psiquiátrico
porque a institucionalização que causa o
rompimento dos vínculos por isso que
atualmente no campo da saúde mental o
que a gente entende como tratamento
tratamento no elenco exclusão mais
inclusão tratamento a inclusão social
o tratamento é a busca pela autonomia
pelo protagonismo pelas possibilidades
de fazer escolhas e não em a exclusão em
eleições então se a gente entendeu que
no campo da saúde mental a
institucionalização não é indicada agora
estamos falando de criança adolescente
então é se esse é um acontecimento se
torna mais grave ainda porque porque nós
mesmos adultos nós chegamos os paramos
um dia pensei 'não não existem algumas
coisas que são fundamentais na criança
que a gente chamou de direitos das
crianças e dos adolescentes nós mesmos
decidimos que algumas coisas são
fundamentais para a presidência de uma
criança para a vida dessa criança e
criamos o estatuto então lá no estatuto
toda criança tem direito à convivência
familiar e comunitária não tem assim
embaixo não tá escrito exceto no caso de
saúde mental né estatuto da criança e do
adolescente para todas as crianças
é portanto parece uma coisa um pouco
esquisita se o tratamento em saúde
mental não preconiza a sua
institucionalização e se no caso das
crianças isso é mais grave ainda porque
as crianças e adolescentes continuam
sendo institucionalizados
eu fui estudar e pensando assim meu deus
no qual qual o comportamento pode ser
tão terrível a ponto de nós mesmos diz
respeitarmos a nossa constituição o que
o que uma criança pode fazer que eu
posso pensar não não
no seu caso o que você o bom pra você é
viver excluído da sociedade e o que eu
descobri foi o seguinte que a a
internação não ocorre por conta do
comportamento das crianças
a internação é ocasionada pelo modo como
a gente trata
vamos voltar lá pra maria eu entendi que
as crianças são encaminhadas para a
institucionalização quando os serviços
não se articula e funciona no que eu dei
o nome de funcionamento e circuito então
vamos pensar lá maria maria quando a
escola se deu conta das dificuldades
dela encaminharam para uma outra
instituição eles chegaram até a dizer
que não tinha porque a maioria frequenta
a escola afinal ela não falava nada e
passava o dia inteiro no bebedouro
portanto a escola não traria nenhum
difícil encaminharam ela para uma
instituição filantrópica
acontece que as instituição filantrópica
era muito longe da casa delas
então a própria instituição encaminhou à
família para que pudesse é pedir uma um
transporte
só que o transporte tem lá alguns
requisitos ea marinha não preenche esses
requisitos
então não podia ter direito a transporte
então já não podia ter direito ao
transporte não poderia ir para a
instituição mas deram uma solução
fizeram um bilhete de transporte para
que ela pudesse usar o transporte
gratuitamente solução essa que não
resolvia nada que a questão não era
dinheiro a questão é que a rebeca mãe da
maria não podia passar o dia inteiro
para levar e buscar um lugar tão longe o
final tinha lá mais quatro filhos
aí encaminharam para o capps mas
encaminharam para o cap não pra ser um
parceiro para pensar no tratamento
encaminhar o caso para que ela passasse
o dia inteiro no carro é como se isso
também foi indicado por que ela ficasse
no caso das 8 a 5 todos os dias
passassem a vida inteira no carlos bohn
dentro deste funcionamento onde uma
instituição vai encaminhando para a
outra é no jogo num certo jogo de
empurra empurra no fim empurrou se tanto
que sobrou para rebeca sobrou pra mãe da
maria todos os cuidados com ela e ela
realmente naquela noite não tinha
nenhuma outra opção além de internar sua
filha
mas qual seria qual poderia ser uma
outra alternativa é o que eu chamei de
funcionamento em rede vão pensar se
maria tivesse lá na escola ea escola
frente às necessidades da maioria ao
invés de excluí la da escola a escola
poderia formar porque eu fiz ali uma
dupla festa numa uma flecha de dois
lados né
a escola poderia formar com essa
instituição filantrópica é dividir os
cuidados da maria tão bom tudo bem é
difícil para mari fica aqui nesta escola
todos os dias quem sabe se ela ficar
dois dias na escola dois dias na sua
instituição em vez de jogo e encaminhar
a empurrar os cuidados como compartilhar
esse cuidado bom eo transporte
vamos pensar bem se uma família com
tamanho vulnerabilidade tamanho
e se esse transporte ao invés de dizer
para essa melhora sinto muito você não
atende os requisitos para o transporte
esse transportes disponibilizados para
atender essa família vão pensar se o
transporte pudesse levar a maria para a
escola e para a instituição filantrópica
e mais esse transporte pudesse devido a
essa situação essa família de tanta
vulnerabilidade transporte pudesse levar
os outros filhos para as outras escolas
aí a rebeca é ter tempo para cuidar dela
mesmo rebeque é ter tempo para cuidar do
tratamento da maioria ela ia ter tempo
para se dedicar à vida dela ea vida de
maria e aí o carro podia entrar nessa
história como um outro a gente né e que
se relacionando com as outras
instituições porque daí a gente forma
uma rede
daí essa família está amparada por uma
rede de várias instituições que se
conversam discutem e se responsabilizam
pelos problemas na rebeca não tem que
resolver tudo sozinho mas esse não foi o
caso
a maioria não tinha lá é maria e rebeca
não tinha uma rede tinham funcionamento
circo em circuito que o final de tudo
era rebeca lá sozinho com a sua filha
tendo que dar conta
a internação da maria durou três meses
ela saiu exatamente do mesmo jeito que
entrou
a família continua exatamente os mesmos
problemas ea situação continua igual
preciso contar pra vocês que depois na
pesquisa é eu encontrei internações
muito longas amárico três meses mas tem
criança e adolescente que ficam vários
meses anos e tem podemos até pensar que
tem algumas crianças que têm a sua
existência condenada ao apartamento do
mundo
vou contar pra vocês uma história porque
eu acho que depois dessa experiência lá
nada nos meus resultados nem eu achei
611 internações 10% eram de autistas e
os outros 90% de outros diagnósticos
eu só queria dizer que eu entendi
com essa pesquisa
meu ponto de vista que não existe
indicação pra a institucionalização pra
nenhum caso pra nenhum diagnóstico para
nenhuma situação
se a gente em algum momento olha uma
criança e pensa eu acho que pra esse
caso isso é válido
eu sugiro que a gente pare tudo entendem
entenda que quem está pensando errado a
gente e não institucionalize e não pense
que uma criança pode viver melhor numa
instituição numa instituição
eu vou parar de falar e deixar que a
raquel que é uma outra moça que me
ensinou muito fale sobre quais são os
efeitos da institucionalização na vida
de uma pessoa
a raquel tinha 11 anos quando teve sua
primeira internação que teve duração de
seis dias a segunda internação já que
foi um pouco mais longa teve duração de
25 dias e ocorreu uma semana depois da
alta da primeira internação
a terceira internação eu destaquei aqui
a queixa a raquel volta a apresentar
quadro de liberação de agressividade e
falta de controle de impulsos por esse
motivo a raquel ficou internada mil e
quatro dias depois raquel sai fica 12
dias em casa e novamente internada na
sua 4ª internação de 413 diz
essa internação ela foge e dois dias
depois ela volta espontaneamente o
hospital
mostrando que esse lugar já estava
ocupando na sua vida no lugar de casa
ela volta e fica lá mas 244 dias com a
cesta internação um psicólogo da
instituição faz esse registro no
prontuário que eu gostaria de dividir
com vocês
a maior dificuldade foi uma inadequação
na convivência com adolescentes sem
problemas psiquiátricos
criou-se um vínculo inadequado de
segurança com o ambiente de internação
ao todo ficou em 1807 dias
aproximadamente cinco anos ela passou
dos 11 aos 16 anos nessa instituição
hoje tem 19 anos e vaga pelas ruas é o
bergson
eu tive o enorme prazer de conhecê lá
tem um domínio da dos conteúdos da
psiquiatria e invejável ela sabe o cid
sabe todas as doenças sabe todas as
medicações são todas as indicações e
contra-indicações conhece o sistema de
saúde mas não teve infância é raquel no
jogo bola aquino ter vizinho arrancar um
experimento adolescência ano teve
namorado não foi o cinema a gente tira
isso dela e aí eu fico pensando qual é o
destino da raquel é justo agora a gente
fala raquel de bobagem vai estudar a
menina vai trabalhar vai ter uma vida
normal eu não sei mas de verdade eu
tenho muita esperança
eu tenho esperança porque aquela menina
mais forte e corajoso que eu já conheci
e nós seremos nós a força de lutar
contra essa realidade
seremos nós a coragem de enfrentar esse
problema
ou a gente vai continuar fingindo que
isso não é problema nós ou a gente vai
continuar aprisionando crianças longe
das nossas vistas
eu espero que não muito obrigado